it's not a Twilight movie
without a helicopter shot
over some mother and woods part two
movie that will credit all the people
who have ever been in a Twilight at the
end of the movie you still wastes our
time with opening credits also this is
the first time in the entire series that
any movie has done this so it's almost
like an implicit message to the audience
we really don't have that much to show
you in part two
but thanks for making us rich movie
picks up with the last movies halfway
point should have it three minutes in
and I'm already skipped I totally
skipped and it landed on something else
I'm gonna have to skip he's under
control
Bella only realizes thirst is a problem
after Edward tells her about it somehow
in five movies the vampire running fast
through the woods effects have gotten
worse wait I get that she's able to see
things slower than real time even while
running but this blossoming dandelion
shot actually goes against that idea
suggesting that she's running super slow
and seeing a full flower bloom and the
time it takes her past movie shows
Bella's spotting a scary ugly spiderweb
in her path but then acts as though she
did not end up with a spider in her
mouth just by skidding past the
aftermath to warn forest running
newlywed vampire forest race goddamnit
also Edward and Bella refused to put on
proper running we're before going out
into the woods to hunt Diddy CGI looks
less P when you place the camera so far
above the action that the CGI becomes
tiny what is this CGI for aunt Bella
senses this rock-climber nearby we
before Edward does and yeah I know he
said a second ago that she's stronger
than him right now but she's got a bit
her nose five minutes into vampirism
than he does as if in response to his
possible death climber slips and
scratches himself right at the time
Bella's thirst for blood hits its
tipping point Gugu shows up so the Bella
doesn't have to kill the deer and her
innocence is maintained let me say
though there are times she's going to
have to kill a puppy just because she
got bailed out this once doesn't make
her innocent for all time also just
because the deer eats grass doesn't mean
it's not an asshole and how do we know
this cougar wasn't gonna eat the
Twilight serial killer in a few years
now that serial killers gonna go free
you ran away from human blood mid hunt
why she's so special that she could
avoid the pratfalls of new vampire
thirst so easily also you just tackled a
mountain lion and killed it with your
teeth no blood on your mouth your face
your dress your hands and that's
literally not possible
since when do you care about Renesmee ya
better not get into that yet but I'm
assuming the FBI will be showing up to
Jacob store soon oh they'll be instantly
slaughtered by a werewolf when they show
but that's not the point
family everyone was concerned about
Bella when she nearly died but
apparently they decided to wait until
after she was done hunting before saying
one word or digital kid continues to be
an abomination in part two I don't care
how good a person she is that's just a
bunch of ones and zeros pretending to be
happy as far as I'm concerned I mean
Jesus could they not get a real baby to
giggle for three seconds for this shot
it's a wolf thing what's a wolf thing
Bella I know you nearly died but you
imprinted on my daughter it wasn't my
choice
she's a baby's not like that well so far
from what these movies have shown us
yeah it kind of seems just like that no
matter what can we just agree that this
premature imprint elation is creepy from
the beginning it was Nessie who wanted
me there Nessie is monster prompts
developer saying this before I could
have a chance to but this super angry
dramatic line reading is completely
neutered by the ridiculousness of the
actual words being said also Bella makes
an insane leak that assumes Nessie can
only mean Loch Ness monster and judging
by Jacobs reaction she's right and how
does she know he didn't nickname the
baby after Elliot ness or Nestor
Carbonell from lost finally finally
finally what what the hell is a scene
the scene couldn't be more in a context
if Bill Condon dropped a scene of
Dreamgirls in its place happy birthday I
stopped aging three days ago
Bella is 100% killjoy so did they build
this house or did they make a good deal
with a witch from Hansel and Gretel was
there an existing hermit house here in
the woods and they snapped it up before
someone could claim squatting rights
what do you think I think it's perfect
you've seen it for all of three seconds
from the outside yep
ten thousand light sources in here
perfect starter home for Bella yeah
let's allow those dangerous candles
throughout the house to burn while we go
have some more fantastic pg-13 sex
I certainly hope so because I'm not
sleeping in a crib with you man do you
know how badly I want one of these books
on the mantel behind them to be
vampirism for dummies or what to Expect
When You're Expecting now I'm wondering
the last time they had sex Edward Brooke
the bed so does the bit not break
because Bella is a vampire now because
that is an extremely specific vampire
power right there vampire sex montage
also whether you realize it or not
you're witnessing the scenes that gave
birth to Fifty Shades of Grey
I love how vampires don't need to eat or
sleep or do much of anything humans do
except for sex then that it's extra
amazeballs
hey we just had amazing mind-blowing sex
let's lie down next to the fire even
though we don't need warmth
we were holding back before yeah that
six we just saw was absolutely the most
violent series of dissolves I ever
watched was it tense i imprinted on my
best friend's newborn daughter sandwich
usually I have to tell him you didn't
make it why can't you just say you got
some colored contacts and when the time
comes seemingly don't age because you
found miracle cream the best option is
to break your dad's heart forever he
solved a problem and that's how that
scene ended with Charlie having no
questions for Jake good at all he just
kept chopping wood after that he'll be
here in 10 minutes
fellas dad decided to wait long enough
to come here just so we can have this
scene and Bella could get some half-ass
human training so irritate your eyes at
first why does she need to go through
any subterfuge at this point didn't
Jacob just tell Charlie about being a
werewolf isn't the expecting the
supernatural at this point oh come on
like she needs to practice doing normal
things just because she's a vampire are
you telling me she's been flashed
running this whole time and hasn't taken
a normal step since she changed because
you're lying to me just don't forget to
move your shoulder so it looks like
you're breathing man you guys way
overestimate the human capacity to
notice human things if she doesn't do
these things well Charlie immediately
snap his fingers point to Bella and say
BAM Bob Cousy I got it move around
blanks Kristen Stewart's acting class
ladies and gentlemen you don't turn into
an animal - my question is when she says
no then what is his next leap of logic
why would Jacob turn into a werewolf in
front of him unless the implication was
vampire or Frankenstein's monster or
customer service rep at Comcast to lose
you again then you want I promise
uncapable promises misschien bills so
much touching father/daughter hug scene
somehow does not contain a beer Charlie
doesn't immediately vomit and run
through the plate-glass window screaming
after seeing this baby because its face
looks less real than that Mike robot
baby face God and Matrix Revolutions
right the adoption I think once Jacob
tells you that werewolves exist you as a
cop should be able to figure this out
with no problem I mean I didn't even
watch the last four movies and I figured
this out armwrestling also Bello is
apparently stronger because the movie
says she is that reason is immensely
satisfying L&L appears fully committed
to Sparkle motion my time as a human was
over but I never felt alive
Vampira new jacob Spanx always seem to
need fixing which suggests to me that
Jacob is terrible at fixing bikes
Edward thinks that we'll find answers in
Brazil he knows a street fighter there
by the name of Blanca the guy is just
electric
[Music]
is she doing here I'll tell you what
though anything to kick-start the plot
is fine by me at this point also Maggie
Grace is at my undead girlfriend of the
sink Renesmee is the most important
character in the story but so far all
you've seen is her growing fast and
jumping really high isn't it about time
we got to know her so we care whether
she lives or dies she's family she'll
come around
that's enough plot-related cheddar let's
stop the movie to play the piano when it
comes down to it this shot represents
all the time this bull movie series is
wasted over the years chess and piano
together at last you mean you didn't
have this vision as soon as Maggie Grace
saw Renesmee because that's when I would
have had it it isn't a Twilight movie if
a member of the Cullen household doesn't
drop something breakable on the floor
this speed over to somebody both is so
unnecessary and it's gotten so old it's
already imprinted on Jacob and an
estimated future child I mean it takes
for an estimated no more of the child
wait are we going to learn some new
thing about vampire rules in the fifth
movie of the series oh we are going to
learn something to think about vampire
rules in the fifth movie of the series
anytime one of these modern vampire
movies flashes back to primitive village
bulls I gotta admit I tuned out faster
than a dad at a Bieber concert this real
woman is made of Barbie parts - fire
kill the so called immortal child also
man good thing this baby is super
flammable what the did I just say so we
fight their offensive weapons are too
powerful you've gotta love these scenes
that seemed like they were written for
the sole purpose of giving everyone at
least one line so they can tell the
friends they were in the movie you see I
help
Connor we have friends all around the
world I won't ask them to fight not
fight witness oh good so now the movie's
plot hinges on eyewitness testimony I
can't wait to see the exciting scenes of
people telling the truth gather as many
witnesses as you can before the snow
sticks to the ground that's when they'll
come because their need to exact justice
on you for having an illegal kid is
contingent upon arbitrary weather
conditions
Alice's instructions were clear but the
shuttle Bella why would she and Jasper
leave at the moment we needed the most
the question I would ask is why would
they leave at the moment you need the
most and not say anything about where
they're going also you know who won the
most during the filming of the Twilight
series people who own helicopters right
now they're taking renessa me around
like some sort of vampire equivalent to
Jesus or every Matthew Mark Luke and
John will bear witness to the fact that
Renesmee is a cute little girl who
doesn't eat people that's the plot right
now folks I didn't make this up it's
true she was born while I was still
human
I've never heard of such a salmon well
man if you've never heard of it it must
be bull right this is how she
communicates what she was using
english-language words in the car a
second ago we're now getting into the
avenged fires portion of the Twilight
story we knew they had a few
seeing the future or reading minds to
all of them having the power of
Quicksilver which was all silly but to
me it's some sense but now they can
control the elements
isn't it fury lurking around well BAM
movie rips off the Vulcan mind-meld from
Star Trek birds flying away signal
something ominous cliche who are they
Senna and zafrina from the Amazon
you know Wonder Woman's friends even the
Beatles really Garrett Emmet and Rosalie
find a fellow vampire in a random
stretch of City just because as more
vampires set foot in their territory
more Quilly it's turned their nature
compelling them to join the pack you
mean like spontaneous combustion also
ensure is a good thing Jakob happens to
be around to hold their hands into this
transition I thought he was busy doing
other but apparently he just hang out in
the woods waiting for random wolf outs
I'm being the acid what an asshole
safrina had power over the mind called
her professor 10 for legal purposes
discount vampire Tyra Banks she's fierce
y'all she could make anyone see what she
wanted them to and yet all the rest of
this movie is allowed to happen it's a
defensive talent so I couldn't read your
mind even before but before more she
wasn't a vampire so yeah whoever's
coming wasn't invited I know that
because I can sense uninvited also I
don't think those chicks from the Amazon
were invited either no one got all wolfy
when they showed up oopah and he always
pardons one person whose thoughts he
claims her repentant this person always
has an ability and they're always given
a place with the guard
couldn't you have slowed ripped some of
this exposition last movie when
nothing was happening
he has no one like which is why she left
why does he need witnesses
see grandma lutz i totally set a line
and everything pax will fight i've never
been afraid of vampires the werewolves
got their asses kicked in the last fight
we saw with vampires but that's because
the plot demanded it I think these
assholes are just wasting a whole bunch
of time killing one Carlisle recruit in
London
why aren't they in Seattle already Wow
all this beats Edward argues with Bella
over Jacobs ABS which is how I've come
to understand the plot over the years
this vampire x-men feel so made up at
the last minute I can't even enjoy it
also for the movies purposes honing
belly shield ability we'll take one
training session out in the woods
Alice made sure only I would get the
message because only my mind would be
safe from ara
so why didn't she just tell you all she
was going to do in the first place also
Alice basically hoped Bella would be
curious enough to check the merchant of
venice for a major clue and that no one
else would notice a torn page clue and
any number of other complications that
could have prevented Bella from figuring
this out but okay
grown half a foot hello who was
determined to do everything to fool her
dad about her vampire identity brings an
11 year old child who should only be
several months old to his house and
doesn't wear those contacts that made
him believe she still had brown eyes
if the concern is that a human knows
about the existence of vampires
shouldn't all these clues count alice's
note gave me a new sense of hope how do
you like that Star Wars fans they just
drank a new hope into this didn't they
also shut up Bela and maybe Jade jinx
was the key
don't you mean Christian Grey and now
she does have her natural eye color did
she popped those contacts in during the
drive here holy s--t
speaking of which they just dragged
Wendell Pierce into this didn't they was
he trying to balance out the quality of
his resume after the wire well that was
the end of a scene time for another shot
of a lonely car driving down the road
Alice's vision was clear Renesmee would
have a future but Edward and I wouldn't
be a part of it of course until her
vision is absolutely proven wrong again
I know now why Alice left me Clues you
do snow sticking to the ground and still
no Volturi damn the director and the set
decorator had a clear dispute regarding
how much Christmas this house needed and
hey there's her natural eye color again
she just can't decide who she's fooling
when can she why do these supernatural
beings need a fire again we sought Jacob
and Edward compared dicks in a snowy
tent back in twilight eclipse and they
were totally fine free battle bonfire
telling war stories this would have been
a bad enough line on its own but then
that's exactly what happens we've been
waiting 1,500 years to return that favor
which means they'll die like bitches in
the big battle tomorrow what is the deal
with this campfire scene anyway why did
they come out here to do this later the
Volturi just show up wherever you are
so you could have slept in your nice
amazing house then trekked down to the
open field the day of the fight right
and I haven't roasted one marshmallow
not one I tell you Carla I've never
thanked you you haven't in like a
hundred years I knew you were an asshole
but Jesus
what is the point of this arrival time
it's like saying to the enemy yeah we
had the element of surprise and we don't
even need that why weren't these wolf
just out in the field with the vamps if
they were going to reveal their
participation in the battle ahead of it
Sun Zoo is rolling over in his grave
Wow they stopped really far away I mean
I know they can hear super awesome but
why even walk this far if you're gonna
stop halfway across the field anyway why
not just chat from the first area where
you ended the clearing you see the child
do not treat us as fools
earlier Carmen said she could feel the
warm blood pumping through her veins
does this guy not can this even be
classified as a dispute hey do I got an
idea
we can feel a lot of time just by having
people walk from one side to the other
and we can film each one walking in real
time and none of that editing bulls it's
genius I tell you ro has a stroke but
because he's a vampire the only symptom
is what a cat sounds like when it
experiments with anal also it should be
noted and this can't be stressed enough
that Michael Sheen is a trained actor
who graduated from the Royal Academy of
Dramatic Art Oh mortal ha immortal this
is a contradiction in terms
it's like saying half pregnant half not
pregnant you and there are York ma'am
okay what the time's up
[Music]
nobody likes you is that the child you
saw this is why you asked questions
first before you go telling everyone
you've seen some you didn't really see
I'm supposed to feel bad for this chick
and when is Liam usen't gonna save her
already the skips off a battle that is
not actually happening at all and is a
huge cheat it's like we have two ideas
we just can't decide between the two of
them so let's do Pope ro is kicked far
away from his army but somehow lands in
the middle of his army movie expects me
to believe that a guy who can't even
play baseball correctly can kick these
two vampires asses because none of this
is real movie steals the everybody dies
scene from all the final destinations
battle boy this is a shot of a CGI wolf
attacking a stuntman what is the point
of battle if she can just mine people to
death
this is suddenly Twilight heroes reborn
the age of Ultron looking in the
background it appears these wolves are
actually winning some battles which
makes me wonder what the hell they were
doing in the last movie
oh no not wait which one was that was it
brawny I think it was brown oh good care
dude punches an earthquake to life which
no one was prepared for but it somehow
instantly sways all the skirmishes in
this battle to the Cullens favor yes
sadly the Willa Holmes succumbed to
vampires over the years hang every
and this is one of those times where I
want to write a sin where I snore and
pretend to wake up and ask if I missed
anything but with this movie I could
literally do that and not miss a thing
because basically this entire climax is
a vision what the hell yeah hang
on - hey guys
even in a world with vampires and
werewolves physics tells us that this
wolf should have killed these two and
himself with that move
but somehow she survives slow-motion
sacrifice wolf also why is there being a
lava 200 feet below the surface
okay so Bella is blocking her from brain
painting Alice why doesn't she bring
pain Bella in that case see told you out
like bitches I could write a better
script than this by taping a pen to my
Johnson and just flopping it around on a
legal pad for a few minutes well maybe
if you've been fighting all along then
if your friends would have died huh
again this movie is a view to the art of
war I'm telling you right now if any of
these shots lasted longer than two
seconds watching the people fight in the
background would be an appalling
experience I mean who are these people
and what are they really doing their
background fodder but the good guys only
had 27 people and the bad guys had like
a hundred but who knows who's really
winning as long as the main good guys
win their fights I guess we're golden
why since when lubey goes the Newhart
Roseanne round for hilarious carpet
pulling it was all a dream finale yep
five movies have build up to a huge
climactic battle that doesn't actually
happen and so the last eight minutes
didn't happen so all that clapping you
did when you saw in Dakota Fanning
getting her head pulled off you take
that back fans also what a very specific
vision Alice just gave to ro like he
apparently saw it with all the different
cuts and camera angles and meaningful
close-ups and since Elaine of
Alice's visions ever been this long
detailed and fully HD also this is gonna
prevent ro from attacking them but just
before this didn't Alice say doesn't
matter what I show you so either she had
a vision of herself saying that it was
wrong or she said that just before the
vision and she was still wrong so why
should anyone take the vision at face
value and couldn't ara use the vision to
now not make the mistakes he made in the
vision what if you were sure she's gonna
mein conceal from the human world could
we leave in peace of course but that
cannot be known actually it can't these
assholes who can reassure are oh that
Renesmee poses no threat show up way
late for some reason as if the script
demanded it for dramatic purposes well
Alice didn't even need to get Mauro a
vision if they had these dickheads
waiting in the wings
be sure to capture the entire walk
assholes we'll wait well gang wait also
were they not going to fight if a fight
happen were those two alone going to
provide a second leave this movie likes
dramatic entrance
way the hell more than common sense race
mr. oh I made hurry Mort
why did you do that were you born
thirsting for human blood
because renessa me wasn't you had no one
to train you and you've turned your aunt
into a vampire who definitely didn't
have any training and Jesus what a bunch
of bull this is and your diet blood
human food I can survive on Island so
human food that regardless the Cullens
have be consorting with werewolves are
natural enemies that's been all five
movies though right this guy wants a
fight so bad he's grasping at straws but
the sparkle by the way this totally also
disproves Alice's earlier vision about
Bella and Edward being unable to live
happily ever after with their kid so she
was totally wrong about everything but
happy ending nonetheless
Alice should show these guys that part
of her magic vision were there diced to
pieces glassy eyes but Jacobs still
gonna age and die way before her right
is a serious stated that wolves live
forever too if it has awful I start
calling you dad see Jacob you are
already thinking about banging a
seven-year-old and I'm baffled the movie
thought this needed including even if
the book did this is some repugnant also
Edward doesn't behead him for saying
this it is this vision ironically
telling us that one day they won't be
together it is coming from Alice after
all me this is the end of the movie and
the series skipped oh good another
previously on all the Twilight's for the
second straight movie nobody's anybody's
love you show me again Edward Cullen
wants to see all the Twilight's again
now starting a 13 minute marathon of
credits including a reminder that
Wendell Pierce actually spent his time
working on this movie oh the humanity
should I start calling your dad
[Music]
not bad mr. Connors you say this is your
first lesson yes but my father was a
piano mover
I'm sorry doctor I have no time to
discuss this logically
remember who are they Senna and zafrina
me Amazon my sword
and you have my bow of my ox captain my
captain did on Alice and uncle Jasper on
a way because we're gonna die loser
thinking use the people gonna die please
for the time being don't force me to
regret our arrangement you just
concentrate on your part
remember I've bled for you once already
how old are you